6 36 walking to raise awareness about
something which impacts a lot of people
here in Las Vegas substance abuse our
Brian will laced up his shoes this
morning to join a man on a mission it's
been a long walk for that man and Brian
you've been walking a little bit too
yes I have guys good morning and we've
been with Cody here this morning walking
and he joins me just barely making it
here for our next hit this morning and
we started off with the Vegas sign and
we've been walking the strip showing
Cody a little bit of Vegas here he's
walked all the way from LA and and Cody
what inspired this walk and what do you
hope to inspire others with yeah so in
2022 I hiked the Pacific Crest Trail
from Mexico to Canada and that was after
going through a process of recovery for
my substance abuse issues so I did this
walk to Vegas to promote the release of
the podcast and to celebrate it at a
podcast movement a convention here and I
hope that um you know maybe even one
person will listen to the podcast see
the story and if they need help they'll
ask for it because that's what changed
things for me is when I finally asked
for help and what was the highlight of
that 200 plus mile you know walk how are
your feet doing and what did you
encounter along the way my feet are okay
my knee hurts I've got some ankle uh
pain going on the Highlight just like
the the Pacific Crest Trail I said the
Highlight was the people same thing on
this walk I I just the kindness of
strangers there was a a burger
restaurant that I didn't have any cash
on me and they were cash only and he
hooked me up with a burger anyways and
then when I got to Vegas and was walking
down the boulevard people were stopping
me uh people who followed me on Tick
Tock were stopping me and saying hi I
got stopped by like seven people and one
of them even bought me food and so it
was just touching and just to experience
Humanity in that way it was definitely
the highlight and the weirdest thing you
encountered along the way I heard it was
a pretty interesting item you found I I
was walking and I saw some bones which
spooked me a little bit but I
investigated for a while and it was a
horse skeleton that had been out there
for seemingly a few years but yeah
full-on horse skeleton was probably the
weirdest thing I found well we'll let
you rest now and of course I think we
need a little bit of rest here so we'll
be uh we'll be sending it back to you
guys back in the station
all right Brian thank you very much
certainly walking for a cause the
Pacific Crest Trail that's no joke
that's a long walk quite an experience
though and it's interesting that people
recognize them you know from the social
media Pages Brian thank you